hey guys a few days ago an actor by the
name of Mark God is to us known as the
touchin stories representative of the
iron bank of Braavos had an interview
with Express in which he confirmed his
return in both of the upcoming seasons
of Game of Thrones and has also hinted
that he might play an important role in
remaining seasons God has said that he
has done four episodes so far and has
also revealed that he will be included
in two more as he said himself he has
done four episodes so far one in season
four one in season five which means that
he will appear in two episodes in the
seventh season almost probably he will
also play his role in two episodes of
the last final season
now that we know Titan stories will
appear in two episodes in the upcoming
season let's see how important his role
will be as I've already said
Titan stories is a representative of the
iron bank of Braavos which is the most
powerful financial institution in the
known world with the fact that the crown
owed millions of gold dragons to the
already mentioned Arum bank which the
War of the five kings drastically
increased this already massive debt to
stern amical levels with all of this
being said it's easy to conclude that
the crown the Iron Throne owes the iron
bank a tremendous amount of money a
massive debt which Cersei Lannister as
the current Queen of the Seven Kingdoms
and the leader of House Lannister is
most certainly not able to repay as the
gold mines of the restaurants have run
dry three years ago in my opinion the
first appearance of the stories in the
seventh season will be the meeting
between him and Cersei Lannister herself
or with a royal official in the
government of the Seven Kingdoms known
as the master of coin however upon
noticing that the crown is not and will
not be able to repay it that the iron
bank of Braavos will decide to as they
usually do support and fund an enemy of
ruler in order to destroy the one that
tops the money in this case Cersei
Lannister and in order to get their
money back which leads to the second
appearance of Taishan stories in the
upcoming season which will in my opinion
being Dragonstone with Tyrion Lannister
the most trusted advisor in the hand of
the Queen Daenerys Targaryen the iron
bank of Braavos is known for remaining
its clients who fail to pay their loans
with the iron bank will have its due
with which we've been introduced in the
fourth season in conversation between
Lannister and Alana Tyrell in which
Elena noted that there is already
mentioned comments saying the iron bank
will have its due as the iron bank
support an enemy of a ruler that fails
to repay their debts
let me also highlight that the iron bank
is a monolithic structure that cannot be
avoided lied to or swayed while it's
also important to highlight one
particular part of conversation between
Tywin Lannister and his daughter Cersei
timing said if you have the money and
you don't want to crumble yourself you
pay it back upon considering all those
facts I came to a conclusion that Teijin
stories representative of the iron bank
whose appearance in the two episodes of
the upcoming season confirmed an actor
himself will firstly have a meeting with
either Cersei or the master of coin
whereupon the iron bank will come to
conclusion that the current ruler of the
Seven Kingdoms is not able and will not
be able to repay the debt of the Iron
Throne
the second appearance of titrant stories
well in my opinion be with Tyrion
Lannister as in my opinion the iron bank
of Braavos will realize that their best
chance of getting their money back is
with funding the nurses campaign in
Westeros as Danny with her two huge
armies along with her allies the
Greyjoy's the Tyrells and sand snakes
have the biggest army the Seven Kingdoms
has ever seen and on top of all of that
the nurse also has three dragons in
conclusion jerem bank of Braavos will
play an important role in the upcoming
season with tightness Tory says it's
representative who will in my opinion
realize that the current crown and the
ruler of the Seven Kingdoms Queen Cersei
Lannister won't be able to repay the
debt of the Iron Throne whereupon the
iron bank of Braavos will decide to as
they usually do fund the enemy of the
crown whom they see as a king in this
case Queen capable being successful in
the long run which Daenerys most
certainly is and as always let me know
your opinion about all of this in the
comment section down below
I'm curious what your thoughts are about
the armed bank and it's representative
touch on the stories who do you think
they're going to support in the upcoming
season I hope you guys enjoyed this
video if you did please make sure to
subscribe to our Channel and I hope to
see you in the next one peace
[Music]